well there was a big celebration in
Nashville for CMT's artist of the year
2016 now this airs tonight and only our
sofa chalets he was backstage with the
big winners now that includes Carrie
Underwood who has been coaching her
hubby up on how to smile during award
shows I told him cuz he generally looks
very stern they'll cut to him and I'm
like can you just smile hopefully he'll
be like looking happy thank you Mike for
just being so supportive
Carrie moved the Nashville audience with
her emotional acceptance speech reacting
to a video montage featuring her and
Mike Fisher's 19 month old son Isaiah in
teary-eyed and I think was seeing my
little guy on the screen
backstage Carrie stopped to congratulate
Lifetime award winner Shania Twain
Carrie can say hello she's trying to
sing during the show we caught the
country legend singing right along to
this star trio special serenade
they're all gorgeous singers it's
emotional for me
Shania was smokin this is what 51 looks
like people after tonight I'm gonna put
out on something really bad I was gonna
say fellow winner Luke Bryan certainly
took notice
I still get starstruck around people
like her yeah your fan going out a
little bit
Luke was on the mend after breaking his
collarbone in a bike accident two weeks
ago and tour mates Little Big Town had
the perfect get-well-soon present come
on up here buddy
and please please be careful on your way
up